this is the first shark to be caught in
the cul of Western Australia moments
later it's shot four times at close
range it's then towed out to sea gutted
and dumped I think it's very sad that a
country like Australia is heading such a
bad example to the rest of the world
Richard Branson is the latest
high-profile figure to condemn the
policy last year australia with praised
all over the world for creating the
biggest marine reserve around australia
and this year and the world is looking
looking at australian and and and
particularly Western Australia and
wondering what on earth is going on are
those like comedian Ricky Gervais a
diver Tom Daley and swimmer Rebecca
Adlington have added their voices to the
antique owl campaign as well as removing
some bait from hooks protesters have
also vandalised government buildings but
the state's premier says he has to do
something we've got the reality of seven
fatalities in three years when we've
only had 20 in the last hundred years
Western Australia is the world's
deadliest place for shark attacks the
cowl has caused much debate I suppose in
a way they have to do something or they
it criticized for not doing anything
about it more patrols probably would
have been a better idea protesters plan
more Beach demonstrations this weekend
they argue there's no evidence culls
reduce attacks kills our shot and after
all it's us who decide to swim in their
territory Jonathan Samuels Sky News
Sydney